Ich freue mich sehr, heute hier im Militärhundezentrum zu sein.
Ich sage ganz offen, ein schöner Termin für einen Bundesminister,
aber auch eine wichtige Einrichtung für uns.
Es ist nicht so wie es aussieht.
Es ist kein Streichelzoo, sondern eine ganz wichtige Einrichtung für die Ausbildung von Hunden.
Ein weltweit anerkanntes Institut, eine weltweit anerkannte Einrichtung,
mit über 2200 registrierten Hunden,
1600 die hier ausgebildet worden sind.
Und die hier auch eine ganz wichtige Ausbildung erleben, um dann auch im Einsatz
gemeinsam mit unseren Soldaten für Schutz und Hilfe zu sorgen.
Heute habe ich die Freude gehabt zwei Labradore zu übergeben, bzw. zu Taufen.
Welche dann auch in weiterer Folge im Einsatz stehen werden.
Ich wünsche den Beiden, aber auch dem gesamten Militärhundezentrum,
alles Gute und viel Soldatenglück.